I don't know if people
know you know his his reputation
precedes him in a way but Shane was an
incredibly kind
um sort of
generous uh pure Spirit um and just an
extraordinary person a extremely funny
guy uh and just I in my my view at
least uh the songwriter of of his
generation I don't know too much about
Irish music you probably know a lot more
about it than I do but I would say he's
you know sitting up there you know
within the whole historical context as
one of the great songwriters yeah Irish
songwriters and greatest great
songwriters per se I think there was
there's a sort of raw honesty to his
work that I've never found anywhere else
really yeah he he always had something
that I didn't quite understand back then
um when I first met him was a genuine
compassion towards people you know he
just he was just kind to people even
though he was costic and sort of uh had
this uh rough Edge to him he was
enormously generous and kind to Ordinary
People oh for sure yeah um you know and
just an extraordinary I'm just it's just
very sad today yeah yeah I have one
story I I'll just you've reminded me of
a story when I I got a call from him
once um and the poges were I think
number two in the charts with fairy tale
and he said come and meet me in King's
cross before it was gentrified come and
meet me in the Wimpy bar in King's cross
we we were living the dream in those
days and I remember I turned up and he
was always an hour late but I suddenly
noticed this commotion and there was two
guys who I thought were homeless
scrabbling about on the side of the road
and one of them was Shan and he'
basically given money to a homeless
person and the notes had blown away and
the both of them were running around
trying to and I remember thinking like I
can't imagine the Pet Shop
Bo scrabbling around in the gutter on
King's cross but it said something about
his sort of yeah authentic I saw that a
lot with him yeah he had he would carry
around a big roll of cash that he would
just give to to give to people
essentially yeah andway